this is a production of cornell
university
uh thank you very much uh for joining us
and i'm sure many of you are thinking
why would you do a webinar in the middle
of a growing season now
uh some of it is that um we want to get
this information
recorded and out there so people can
access it and then reuse it so many
many more people will be watching the
recording of this
so my job really is very easy to
introduce my wonderful colleagues here
that i've had the pleasure of working on
with this project
for a little over uh 14 15 months now
probably longer than that that we maybe
conceptualized it
and really what it was was bringing the
bmp
practices to life how do we understand
why or why not some of the key practices
that we
think are best for protecting uh water
quality and pollinators
um are either implemented effectively or
not implemented effectively so we can
find out the strength and weaknesses
of our approach to getting them adopted
and then move in that direction and so i
have the pleasure of introducing
my program assistant carl scamenti
uh program manager for our turfgrass
program and
golf course engineer extraordinaire
he'll give us some data on the
background of this project that we've
collected so far
and then my esteemed colleague the
former superintendent at locust hill
and that's and at center point i think
he'd want me to say
uh a golf club uh in in his
a lifelong golf course superintendent
rick slattery host of more than 20
uh lpga events uh during his time at
locust hill so here's a guy who knows
what he's talking about
from the mom and pop operation all the
way uh to the highest level that the
profession has practiced so without any
further ado carl why don't you talk to
us a little bit about
the nature of this project what the data
is that we're acting from
and then rick's going to talk about the
practices thank you very much
yeah thanks thanks for the introduction
frank uh you know it's interesting you
mentioned the word engineer you call me
an engineer
in the opening but really we're working
with a bunch of engineers
um at the rit's new york state pollution
prevention institute p2i
they're housed in the scalisano
institute of sustainability but
but these folks have done this sort of
project in a bunch of different
industries
um you know they've done an auto auto
industry they're doing it with wineries
furries
these best management practice focused
versions of this in different industries
but they have a very kind of uh process
oriented approach to
driving adoption of best management
practices and so there's a very kind of
stepwise approach going here so the
first one is
is pretty obviously we have to define
our bmps
and frank you were very significant in
codifying the new york state golf course
bmps for protecting water quality
back in the early 2010s one of the first
states in the united states to
really codify these things in a document
so for us we sat around
for for months really and decided which
which one of those are the most
important which ones do we want to
figure out
uh what golf courses in our region are
doing so we kind of pick and choose
chose a lot of those bmps from this
document
as our starting point and we created a
survey so then okay we have to
evaluate adoption and we have to go out
and administer this survey
and again one of the things the erp
folks do is they basically define their
boundaries they call it a universe of
facilities so we defined our boundaries
into these
counties in upstate in western new york
central upstate western new york maybe
the vernacular there on what is uh
upstate new york changes based based on
where you are but
they defined our region and then they
said they counted up all the golf
courses
used some statistics to say okay you
need to evaluate randomly pick 40
facilities
administer this survey to get a
representative sample
and the random selection here is
important because you know i think when
we've looked at bmp adoption in the past
whether that's a
gcsa national survey or even us doing
some surveys
um it was never truly random right and
survey bias happens when
the people who respond to surveys are a
certain portion of people and maybe
you're leaving out some people so our
ability to really randomly sample
to take our time to to get all these
golf courses
uh was a big deal big deal and it makes
the data very
uh useful so we'll look at that data in
a second
but the third step is once we get all
that data is to really kind of do the
intervention phase and that's where we
are now it's through these things like
webinars podcasts
um kind of our seminal core document is
this uh
this poster in the middle golf course
sustainability practices poster we sent
this
in the mail to all 200 golf courses in
our region
and then we've also posted it online
hopefully people have
have seen that and can print it out
themselves but basically we've distilled
the core concepts of these bmps that we
chose to focus in
on onto this poster and to give you kind
of really a snippet version of
uh you know what the bmp is and why it's
important
um to create awareness for a lot of
people who may just not know about bfps
um so we hope we have to do field days
as part of this kind of
education phase as well uh and we'll
write up case studies as we go along and
do some
uh some interesting some brief
assistance work we call it with with
courses one on one so
um this whole phase that's going through
this summer and will bleed into next
year a little bit
is all about creating awareness and
driving adoption into key bmp areas
and then the final step step four is uh
to go back again and say did it work so
we'll do that same survey process
40 random golf courses again and see if
if the work we did worked and we hope it
does this is what we're going to try and
do but
that's an important part is to see if if
we can drive adoption in some
some meaningful way so we split
our bmps into these four categories like
water
nutrient management uh pest management
and
point source pollution today obviously
we're going to focus on the water
the water component with rick we're
going to do three more
webinars like this focusing on the other
areas
um but i thought it was important to
look at the data okay what did we find
when we did these surveys
um so you notice some interesting things
the um
the highly adopted ones you know between
three quarters of people
visually check all their irrigation
heads every year right that's something
we
we hope everybody would do can can
visually look at if all their heads are
operating at the beginning of the season
allowing some moisture stress right we
want some people to
dry their turf down make it a little bit
more resilient not rely
so much on everyday frequent watering
and then eliminating irrigation in
autoplay areas so all this kind of
speaks to
not only making the turf stronger but
saving water
and generally courses in our area are
are good at that
but there are also things we're not so
good at and there's different reasons
for this we'll get into that but
using a moisture meter only 20 percent
of golf courses in our region
uh have a moisture meter and use it uh
even fewer use evapotranspiration data
when they're planning their irrigation
so those are two kind of technologies
that that people haven't adopted quite
quite to our liking in these areas um
and then some documentation things so
having a map of where runoff goes on the
golf course
only 12 percent of golf courses have
that in our region and a drought
emergency
plan not something we think about in new
york maybe that's southwestern
united states sort of thing
thing to have but as we go through
climate change as water
comes less frequently but in larger
amounts through rainfall
uh we're going to start to need to think
about that in new york state and
and it's been clear that we haven't
really thought about that um
so far so this is some of the data we've
seen we're going to target our education
towards this
uh but but just as important as the data
was the conversations we had with
superintendents
um and that it's not kind of cut and dry
that that you
do or don't do a bmp there's reasons for
that
some of the reasons i would say are you
know quote-unquote controllable
um you might just not be aware of the
bmp you might not know about it
um there might be this old-school
mentality i don't want to say that's a
bad thing but
um especially with with new technologies
like moisture meter or using et data
there can be some hesitancy to adopt
those sorts of things
uh and then of course fear too when we
say things like hey allow some moisture
stress
there is a fear on the superintendent's
behalf of well i i don't want my my turf
to die
um so those are are things that you can
kind of control they're not
limited by um your ability to spend
money on your infrastructure
but they're more kind of knowledge based
but there are these other things that we
found
limit someone's ability to adopt a bmp
and those are things like
costs of a moisture meter right 1500
that's an expensive thing for
for some facilities labor the ability to
go out and stout or visually check
irrigation heads
uh that's tough when you only have two
full-time people at a golf course the
infrastructure golfer expectations play
into this too so
it was it wasn't quite black and white
when people did or didn't do a bmp and
that was
what led us to wanting rick's brick to
come on and talk
about his practical experience as a
superintendent
um so rick as i uh get out of this
screen and let you
transition to yours i'll just say that
that rick
slattery has been a really important
part to frank and i
in this education phase and building
this project
because he has this practical component
this
ability to explain okay here's why
people may or may not do this sort of
thing that is
a lot less cut and dry than we'd like to
think which is hey just go do it
um so we're going to hear from rick
today about his experiences as a
superintendent
in these kind of black and white in this
gray area in between the black and white
um and how he was still able to adopt a
lot of these bmps
and uh and he'll talk about that today
okay uh thanks colin frank and uh
i'd like to start by just saying that uh
my career
uh working on golf courses began in 1970
and i've seen and witnessed a lot during
that time
i would like to share some of some of
what i witnessed during my career and
mix that in with what i learned during
this project
while completing the surveys we
encountered a wide spectrum of golf
courses and i've worked at all of those
different types at one point or another
during my career
from small public municipal one owner
semi-private
one of the best in the world old kill
and i also
hosted the lpga for 19 years at locust
hill country club
and because of the variety of golf
courses we visited during the surveys we
also encountered
a wide variety of types of irrigation
systems which i will show
here and i can say also say that i've
operated all of those types at one point
or another in my career
now in my opinion water management is a
cornerstone of bmp
everything starts with that and
everything else seems to branch off of
that it seems more water that we use the
more fertilizer we use and that leads to
more fungicides
and the ball just gets rolling down in
that direction
but more import breeds more input
and i hope to show during these slides
that improving uniformity
is the key to success
this is a roller basing system that we
encountered quite a few of our golf
courses it's not much different than
a person that was gonna water their home
lawn
uh it's very rudimentary uh you have a
quick coupler valve
off to the side of the green which plug
a hose into
and move this roller base around on uh
you know onto the dry spots the green
and
and that's how you get your green water
but
with these rudimentary manual systems
it's it's really impossible to keep up
with replacing the daily wash
loss of water or e.t just just due to
their limited capacity to pump water
a lot of these guys are hooked onto
municipal water or they're just pumping
out of a small pond on the property
and they just have a limited amount of
water that they can get out and
they get into an extended dry spell and
they're not watering fairways
uh they they're just uh basically trying
to keep the greens alive uh
never mind trying to keep up with the et
or anything like that they're just
trying to keep keep
their greens alive and and get maybe get
a lot a little bit of water on their
tees
but ironically uh during our visits i i
saw some very high percentage bank grad
screens that
in some of these smaller public golf
courses and i attribute that to the
limited amount of water that the greens
were getting
one course that i visited actually had
one valve for three greens so they not
only had to
move the roller basin from around on
each green
but they also had to move it around uh
from green to green
uh this is the next step up and this is
a
quick coupler system with impact
sprinkler
and uh to operate a system like this uh
you basically usually had
uh this i had one of these at center
point country club you'll have two
two valves these quick couple of valves
here um
around the green uh maybe a couple in
the t and if you're lucky you'll have a
row of them up the fairways
but the typical uh way to operate these
was we would come in at
about midnight and get our pumps all
primed up and
probably get our first set out around
one o'clock now
usually you put a sprinkler in on one on
each hole
and to move that sprinkler take would
take roughly 45 minutes to an hour
to uh tour the golf course and move the
sprinklers so
with three sets in the greens uh
starting at one we'd be done at four
o'clock in the morning we'd be done with
two sets with the t's at six and then
we'd have a groundskeeper that would
come in at six and we'd put our first uh
first impact sprinkler in the fairway
and have a groundswell and move that up
our fairway until we're done maybe
around one or two o'clock in the
afternoon
now um just the with these
type of manual systems uh they provided
a self-imposed
restraint from over watering just
because of the simple
just because of the difficulty of
operating them
uh if i saw a little bit of wilt in a
fairway at three o'clock in the
afternoon you know i'm not gonna go
through the process that i just
described
to get a little water on the golf course
um
and because of the difficulty of running
these systems we strive to make it from
rainstorm to rainstorm
just so we wouldn't have to come in at
night and start watering so
we did everything we could to strengthen
that turf so that we wouldn't have to
come in at night and water now striving
for better uniformity i made actually
two changes with this system
i couldn't change the run times because
obviously they're 45 minutes to an hour
to make a tour around the golf course so
i changed the nozzle sizes instead
and we color-coded them so we could we
could see them at night
and we put the large nozzles into the
dry areas and we put the smaller nozzles
into the wet areas
and uh we achieved pretty good
uniformity that way and the second thing
i did was i eliminated the night
waterman position
and began uh watering myself with my
assistant at night
and i just felt it was just too watering
the golf course properly was just too
important
uh not to get it right and as soon as we
started doing that
i saw a huge improvement in the golf
course and the playability of the golf
course
the next step up from that was uh to go
to either the single row or a double row
automatic system and
you can see here the area uniformity
basically extends
out to the last main line here
uh on the on the system if you had a
single roll system it's the the
uniformity was
would even shrink up even more than that
now as you can see the difficulty here
is that
uh you're getting proper uniformity
between the between the lines because
you're getting overlap from each head
but outside that main line you're only
getting half the amount of water that
you're getting in the middle of the
fairway
so uh and and to add insult to injury
what happens along this edge of the
fairway here you get the pickup pass
with your fairway mowers
uh you've got golf car traffic running
down through there and
and you're only getting about half the
amount of water so that's a high stress
area
uh also uh so because of that
uh spin rate was very important to me
when i was
operating these systems i wanted to make
sure that the
sprinkler could make a full rotation
during the lowest run time that i would
use
reason being is let's say if i turn the
sprinkler on here
and it started here and it turned around
here but it shut off here
as it was coming back around well that
area outside that main line
now is not getting half the amount of
water but it might not get any water at
all
so i always wanted to make sure my heads
would turn
make a full rotation during the lowest
run time that i would run
now the other uh aspect of these systems
was sometimes they would
come in a block system more than
one valve might operate two sprinklers
or might even operate four sprinklers
so i would i used my uh knowledge that i
used about changing nozzles out
from uh the prior system and uh
basically uh did that with these block
with these block systems
um let's just say the upper part of this
fairway is dry
and the lower part of this fairway is
wet well i would put
the a bigger nozzle into the upper into
this sprinkler here in the upper portion
and put a smaller nozzle
down here uh where it was wetter but as
i noticed in
in the 1970s and the early 80s as more
and more automatic systems were added to
golf courses that the playing surface
started to change
and in some good ways and some not so
good ways i noticed they began taking on
that lime green power look
at the time i didn't know it was power
but i did notice they were the
the golf courses that were being
irrigated in this way
took on a different color and i just
i found out that in witness that
i felt that less water promotes stronger
healthier turf grass
and back then i lived by the motto of
tough love and lean and mean
and uh the less water uh the healthier
the healthiest surface that you had um
this was a
infrared photo that i had taken when i
first came to locust hill
you can see that the poor uniformity
here on the edges of the fairways
you can see the good uniformity here up
around the green
you can see how it's a nice uniform
color it's a nice pinkish reddish color
you might have smaller sprinklers around
the green you might have small
less spacing do a little hand watering
that's the reason you might get a little
better uniformity there
but as you come out of the fairway here
uh you know you get more acreage they
you know the designer might have spread
the spacing out a little bit
uh you got bigger sprinklers and uh you
know you just start to get some poor
uniformity here
um now when i went to locust hill
country club now
and in the way that golf courses
basically dealt with
this problem was they would water for
the dry area
and make that dry area look like the
green up here well what happened in the
center area
was it was getting extremely over
watered
and when i went to locust hill uh
one of my directives was to uh correct
that
uh golfers were landing balls here in
the center of the fairway they were
plugging they weren't rolling
um there was a high amount of paul anya
probably 90 95 percent pelania a lot of
thatch
and then out here on the edge if a ball
landed out here on the edge a ball would
bounce and skip and
roll away so you know to correct that uh
inconsistency was was something that i
was charged with when i
when i uh arrived at locust hill and i
came to the conclusion that it just
became too easy to water with automatic
irrigation systems to match the poor
uniformity
you know back if you had to like i say
operate that manual system
you think twice uh if you all you're
doing is going in pushing a button in
your office to turn it on
it's a lot easier to do that and in my
opinion
all this over watering led to weaker
turf grass that required more pesticides
more fertilizer
and more water to survive on a side note
i think wetting agents can help with
uniformity and
quite a bit with uniformity and they are
actually cost effective for smaller
clubs
uh i think you can find a find a good
good
good wedding agent for a good price but
it comes down to managing the drives
for the dry spots and this is one way
that
i had to deal with it at locust hill was
i had to by turning down the automatic
irrigation system
uh we ended up uh focusing more on hand
watering those dry areas and that way
uh getting better uniformity and better
playability
uh but who can afford to do this um not
many golf courses can afford to do this
and what i would do is uh if i had a lot
of people available for hand watering i
would rely on the automatic system less
if i didn't have very many people
available that day or that week i would
rely on that i would probably turn the
automatic system on a little bit more
um during i can say that during the
weeks leading up to the lpga
i relied on the automatic system less
and less and i focus more on hand
watering like this
and the other reason i did that was i
wanted to dry the golf course out as
much as i could
to build up a reservoir so if any
rainfall did fall during the during
tournament week
the golf course would absorb it readily
from there uh actually i used that
infrared photo with locust hill
and i was able to sell the need for a
new irrigation system at locust hill
i was able to show them the defects that
they had and how we could improve that
and as you can see with the triple row
um there's
three main lines of water and the area
of good uniformity extends out to the
edge of the fairway so you're extending
that uniformity out even further
which is a big help the other thing that
uh is is
uh it's consistent with these three roll
systems that you get individual head
control
so you can turn on each head uh
sprinkler
with a different run time than the other
ones so the uh
focus on changing nozzles was was a lot
less because i could change the runtimes
but the large these these system here
have large capacity and
i could i could my my system at local
still
could have the ability to pump 1800
gallons a minute
that allowed me to have a two and a half
hour water window in other words i could
water the greens tees and fairways in
about two and a half
hours so i could wait until the last
possible minute
uh and see a lot of wilt out there
before i turn the irrigation system on
and i could also wait till about five
o'clock in the morning if i thought we
might get some rain at night
and trying to turn the system on when i
get into work
and i can have a golf course water by 7
30.
but some of the drawbacks in it with
these systems here
is number one it's really easy to
overwater
you can just really just over water
really quickly and and and it's very
it's
it seduces you and before you know it
the golf course is over water
the other thing that's challenging is i
had 1400 heads 1400 sprinklers at lopes
till
and to visually check all those and keep
them all operating properly
was a challenge and i think what you'll
see is with a lot of the upper tier golf
courses
is that they hire an irrigation tech and
that's only that's just their job to do
that
alone so how does irrigating affect the
water holding capacity of the soil
especially over watering well i devised
this
graph here and it's not driven by any
data that i had but it's
purely conceptual but
if you take this solid line here in the
center and we call that the saturation
level of the soil
uh and let's say the threshold a here is
this dotted line that is where you would
turn
normally turn your irrigation system on
so as your golf course down here dried
out a little bit you turn the irrigation
on and
you get this kind of a flow here um but
then what happens when you get an inch
and a half of rain
you spike up into this wet area up to
here
you might dry out a little bit you get
more rain and then as you start coming
down to a dry period you might get
passed
back to saturation level but if you get
another couple inches of rain or
whatever you're back up here where
you're just too wet again
so what what drives this threshold
a is a lot of things uh you know you
might have a lot of power you might have
short boots
uh you might have members that we want
you to keep the greens that so that they
can hold
but what thrives in that zone greens
that hold
golfers like that weak turf grass piano
short roots
more bombard damage the bomb damages is
really really severe
you can get some deep deep splattering
ball marks if you keep your greens
wet all the time and also high disease
pressure i'm getting a lot of
that turf canopy is wet all the time
you're going to have a lot of disease
pressure
so what i did with oak locust hill was i
tried to drive that threshold down down
down to where you see
it down here below and the way i did
that was i just
every dry spell that we got i just let
the golf course try to let the golf
course dry out a little bit more than
the last time
and i'd have some dry spots show up and
we'd hand water those and if we had to
we verify them and get some
stronger turf grass you know installed
in those areas
but that's it's a slow process but i
would like to say that
should point out that locust hill had
heavy soils in the fairways
and greens were modified push-up but the
roots were growing deeper than the cup
cutter
and they were growing into the plant
material
so what thrives in this song down here
below
you've got firm greens but the fairways
are firm and they have a lot of rolls so
the golf course actually plays a lot
shorter
and the members like that uh stronger
turfgrass you might have bent grass
uh but perennial poet too i found that
we'll adapt to the
those conditions and will act a lot like
uh bent grass uh if it if you give it a
chance to
deeper roots ball marked damage is less
severe
you might get a little skip skip mark or
a little smudge mark but you don't get
those deep deep ball marks
and very loaded disease pressure with a
dry turf canopy all the time
um you know very little very little
disease pressure
and i feel like the pre the proof was in
the pudding with the lpga here in 2013
we had had an extended drought uh prior
to the tournament
and wednesday night prior to the
tournament
starting on thursday morning i had the
golf course about as dry
as i could get it and we had rain start
thursdays during thursday's round
thursday morning
and thursday's round was canceled and we
got about two and a half inches of rain
in about 12 hours
well i can tell you that we never even
got back to saturation level with that
amount of rain because of how dry i had
the golf course
on friday morning we had tee times on
time seven o'clock
and everybody was calling rick a hero
but uh i could tell you i really didn't
do anything
the only thing i did was i was able to
drive a golf course out to this level
so that we when we did get uh that heavy
rain
uh the golf course sucked it up like a
sponge and the other
one other thing i'd like to point out
here is uh i'll show a moisture meter
later on
but a moisture meter can help you put a
number on these threshold lines here
and it can help you uh manage for those
uh
quite a bit better this is a
simple catch can test um to show
this and it can show you the same
information that you saw
on the infrared photo by setting these
out
um you can determine uh
what kind of coverage you have what kind
of uniformity you have
um but i would like to point out uh the
compound effect of the differences
that you might see in the collection of
the water of these
these cups let's just say that uh up
here
next to the water the sprinkler um i get
uh a one tenth of an inch of water in
that cup
let's say three tenths of an inch of
water here next to the sprinkler
and then out here i'm getting maybe a
tenth of an inch of water in the cup out
here well
operate that system over let's say 10
times over the next 10 days
well now you've got next to the
sprinkler here you've dropped
essentially three inches of rain
whereas out here you've dropped on the
outer edge you maybe only drop one inch
of rain
that's quite a discrepancy so that
compound effect of the differences in
your system
can really create problems down the road
and
one of the things i've always done is
i've always converted my irrigation run
times from minutes
from minutes to inches and compared that
to rainfall amounts
i always like to know if i ran the
system for 10 minutes then let's say i
was get putting out
what would be equal to a quarter inch of
rain uh
this uh catch can test doesn't have to
be this sophisticated
um i've even gone and put out just
simple
rain gauges a couple two three plastic
rain gauges and just
got my determination there to see how
much water i was applying
as a related to rainfall
you want to know how much you're using
in relation to how much
how much rainfall you're actually
replacing i had a colleague of mine
and he's paying for city water and has
to be budget conscious about what he's
purchasing and spending
and he found that just by reducing
fairway run times by two minutes
he was able to save enough water to
water his greens and teas
so you want to know how much you're
using how much water you're using
and here is a water meter a moisture
meter
uh that we wanted one to point out here
and it has a number of benefits it can
as i said beef earlier it can put a
number on those threshold lines
in the previous slide uh it can also
provide the same data
uh that you saw in that infrared photo
and uh you can compare weather
fluctuations and irrigation run times
with the moisture meter data
after it rains you can go out and and
see uh maybe what a quarter of an inch
of rain does to the
does to the soil and underneath your
greens how much how much did this number
go up
but basically uh by putting these prongs
into the green it'll give you a number
and give you a baseline number of let's
say if that gets down to 11 or 12 and
you know you got to turn the irrigation
system on
but the benefits of a moisture meteor
are that it will they take the guesswork
out of when the water
they can provide the data can provide
owners and members with information on
how and when you water
if they ever ask questions you can show
them exactly what how your decision
making process
is and it provides data for
municipalities on your irrigation
practices in the event of water
restrictions
and in in both cases it just shows that
responsible water use of your water
resources
if you cannot can't afford a moisture
meter i would suggest at least using a
soil probe
i've used these my my entire career can
give you a lot of information
i can tell you how much thatch you've
got here
in the soil it can show you if you have
any layering in the soil
that would prevent water from moving
down through the surface
uh you can see how quickly your greens
are drying out how deeply they're drying
out
and i think it just provides it's just a
good idea to provide
for have a good visual check under the
surface every once in a while
to poke that thing in there and your dry
spots whatever and see what's going on
and i fashioned one of these out of a
broken golf club
uh i actually took a broken golf club
sawed it off cut it off here
and ground out a window in here and
use that and i can also say that
superintendents at the smaller clubs i
worked at
they were always the ones to change cups
a lot of information
can be learned from your cup cutters uh
that you're taking out a six inch plug
out of your green almost every day
and uh you can look down in there and
see what's going on and
how wet how wet your green is and how
quickly it's drying out and
just provide you with a lot of
information throughout my career
i've always used weather data to make my
irrigation decisions
as far back as i can remember
this is my office in the in the late
1990s
and you can see here on the right i was
subscribing to dtn weather service
i had a satellite dish outside my shop
i was getting up-to-date information on
the radar coming in
and they would also supply me with
weather data that i could use
on the left hand side here it was my pc
with my software for my irrigation
system
and i would use the weather data to make
my adjustments
with my irrigation software so if i have
any advice i would say try to think of
irrigation as supplemental to rainfall
and not as a replacement for rainfall
today weather data is free at your
fingertips and
you can get pull up any app and you can
get
weekly uh forecasts you can get hourly
forecasts
over here on the right you can uh noah
has a good website
where you can pull up a 10-6-10 day
outlooks 8 to 14 day outlooks
it's just good to know and you know have
a pretty good idea what the trend is
going to be in the next 10 to 14 days so
you can kind of set up your irrigation
practices uh
you know going into those periods but
you know i can point out here if it's
going to be warmer than normal cooler
than normal
wetter than normal drier than normal and
i think that's all good information
uh now we'd always talk about a lot
about et for being with bmps and to uzt
uh but we found during our surveys that
there were a lot of a lot of guys out
there that didn't know what et was and
in fact uh the the engineers at rit
uh weren't familiar with uh et either
but et is basically the reverse of
rainfall
it's a measurement of water leaving the
soil by evaporation and transpiration
and it helps with when deciding when to
water and how much uh
in theory essentially if i'm at the
point where i need the water and i got
an inch of rain
and let's say i'm averaging uh
about two tenths of an inch of uh
water loss or et each day well that
means in about five days i'll be
right back where i started from and then
looking to probably need the water
but basically et is a calculation of
solar radiation temperature humidity and
wind
and in the absence of et if you can't
find it anywhere or don't have access to
it
all that information here is on your
weather apps you got the temperature
you got partly cloudy you get the sun
you've got uv index
humidity wind you can just kind of
generally look at those things and
decide what kind of a day is going to be
uh we used to call uh
the the worst days that uh we we saw for
water loss were what we call high sky
days
high sky day would be no clouds low
humidity
uh maybe around 80 degrees and
some wind and those days would
would really perk up perk up your ears
and get out there and keep an eye on
your greens because
you're probably losing water uh faster
than uh out of the plant then the plant
roots can replace it
and that's when you get the wilt and
that's where you might have to run a
syringe or
do a little hand watering but basically
in the absence of et if you can't find
that anywhere don't have access to it
the two the things i looked at probably
the most was dew point
and nighttime temperatures and dewpoint
can tell you a lot
and i made a lot of mistakes in my
career
uh by just concentrating on temperature
and you get up into 95 degree temps
and we're all thinking oh my god it's
hot we got a water
but if that dew point is at the high 60s
or even into the 70s
you're not losing any water and if in
those kind of situations
um i would just maybe do a little quick
syringe during the day or maybe a little
hand watering
but you're not losing any water out of
the soil and
when i lost the most grass that i
probably lost in my life was when i
my water during a situation like that
and then now i've got to look to sit the
the the golf course is too wet
you can't dry it out and you start
getting black algae start getting
rotting
you know disease starts kicking in and
that's when i would really
have a lot of problems and that's why i
always like to stay on the drive
dry side of things i always felt like i
could add more water
but if i got the golf course too wet i
just could never dry it out
and so where do you find et if you don't
have a
weather station on site that calculates
that for you
your best bet and the only bet you have
is really to subscribe to a service like
t3 golf or dtn weather sentry
and they can provide you with a ton of
information here et rate
radiation soil temps leaf wetness
all that can be at your finger
fingertips here's et
on an hourly basis you can get it on a
daily basis
but again these cities
services can be a little pricey but you
know eighty five dollars seventy five
eighty dollar eighty five dollars a
month
upwards to thousand dollars for a year
and i can honestly say that if i had a
thousand dollars to spend
i would probably opt to purchase a
moisture meter because it's a one-time
cost
and it can pretty much provide me with
pretty close to the same information
but i'd like to say just point out that
weather data is crucial
to sound water management
and as my last slide here i just like to
say that
a simple visual check can can save a lot
of headaches down the road
i wouldn't buy this piece of property
about quarter five
every morning when on my way to work at
locust hill
and every morning i'd see this one
sprinkler here that was malfunctioning
and just dropping water out into the
pavement
and this went on for about six weeks and
i kept wondering when they were going to
fix this
and then finally as these trees started
to dry and dropped their leaves and the
bushes started to dry out and
the grass was dead from here up to here
and
uh finally uh i came through and uh this
head was fixed
and i guess the lesson learned there is
i would say is
don't wait till you get dead grass and
and dead shrubs and dead trees
before you fix your irrigation system uh
try to get out there and do a visual
check ahead of time
and be proactive and get these things
fixed
before you create your problems down the
road so i'd like to end with uh just
saying that no matter what type of
system you're working with
if it isn't working properly it's just
not going to give you what you want
you want to try to maximize the
performance of whatever system you
have that you're working with and with
that
i'll uh send it back thanks
rick thanks rick carl before we
uh get some comments from you and and i
wrap up here
uh i just want to say what a joy it is
to take that uh
historical view of this i'm so glad we
have this
uh on tape now to for for others to
listen to because you did a wonderful
job of
of really taking us through from the
various levels of the way you want to
get uniformity
and let's just say that last picture is
a good example that little strip of
grass plus the flower bed there
these are not easy areas to water
they're not easy because they're
topographically challenged you've got
different plants maybe there
and and you know heads are out there
1400 things that can get hit
and it's hard to keep track and it's
hard to do and so
finding the keys like rick said uh to
making it simpler to conceptualizing it
to make it
a little bit easier to do by doing that
rick you said
in some cases you're able to maximize
your labor resources right and that's
what i think one of the things we've
learned from this project
is your interaction with half the golf
course superintendents that aren't
members of the gcsa and don't have the
kinds of systems that we
typically talk about in these webinars
that assume
you can do all those technological
things so big shout to you rick thanks
for doing that
i do have a big question for you and
that is
you know when you um start to make a
transition like i just listen to you
and i'm hearing you say you know i
probably got to dry this out a little
bit more it's not likely my system works
really well
but you know what i got a lot of polar
right now
i got a lot of annual bluegrass that i
want to keep a lot can you tell me
the process you go through when you're
thinking about making these shifts to
to to use water more efficiently or a
drought emergency plan comes in
and you're forced to use water more
efficiently
what did you see in those transition
times when you
had one grass that was sort of a a sin
of riches water fertilizer right all the
things maybe we do a little too much of
how did that transition look for you
well uh i think that that's that comes
in with education i think you definitely
have to educate your members and you
have to educate your owners
and everybody has to kind of buy into it
uh
but to me it was a lot it's a lot like
an addiction
and you can go cold turkey you can kind
of kind of go
slow um but uh
again i would always uh uh would
make my decisions basically based on uh
again golfer expectations i think a lot
of guys
uh job security is a huge thing um
you know when when it comes down to am i
going to turn that irrigation on
and keep my job or am i going to let it
dry out and let the power weaken up a
little bit
but i think the big key that i would i
would talk about
is is the selection of species i mean
what do you want to grow look at your
green look at your fairway
what have you got and then try to main
manage to the strongest denominator a
lot of times we manage to the weakest
denominator
and we take the what weakest turf is and
we water to that
but what i always try to do is i always
manage to the strongest denominator
and you take the weakest denominator and
try to build that up and strengthen it
so it can handle what the stronger
grasses are doing so i think look at
your turf
look at what you've got it's okay to let
that polar turn a little off color
i think and in that way it's not so
quite so puffy and doesn't make your
green quite so bumpy
but it's all it's all your own comfort
level
and your own confidence level with how
far you want to push some of these
things
yeah and certainly a little bit more
dramatic in
fairways right where you have a little
more tolerance for a little bit weaker
grass
a little bit trickier to do on putting
surfaces when you're trying to get plane
quality and
keep people moving through but but it
sounds like what you said
and carl i'll pass it to you is is
rick's the real long view here
the real ecological view you know pick
the
you know the survival of the fittest and
i'm gonna help what i'm going to pick
that species and i'm going to
manage it because in the long view it's
going to be the
more resilient species thanks very much
rick carl i'll pass it back to you
yeah so i think continuing on that
thread frank you know i think of it
almost as an evolutionary
evolutionary kind of management system
you you employed rick both at
locust hill and center point where you
took this long view converting
kind of poa areas into bent grass areas
but even you yourself
you almost responded evolutionarily when
you were at center point this idea that
you had three different sprinkler heads
in the impact sprinklers a
a small head for areas that would
collect water a big head for the areas
that
maybe she did water more um
you know and i'm thinking about the new
kind of crop of superintendents coming
out these days who have
immediate access to an automatic
irrigation system most likely and they
didn't get a chance to learn the lessons
that
you got to learn at center point and
then moving up through the industry
what advice would you have to those
people who kind of start with
you know the cadillac systems the
ability to push a button
whereas you got to learn you know kind
of these these
ways to manage water that were very
judicious because of your system
inadequacies early on what advice would
you have to those sort of people who
are thrust right into a nice system and
can probably get it's very easy to over
water
initially yeah um
i probably a lot of people don't agree
with me on this but i think everyone
should probably start out operating in a
manual system at some point in their
career and
before they're given the keys to the
ferrari um
you know uh but uh you know i think
visually check
i think the biggest thing is you learn
uh when you're when you're manually
operating a system you you learn
uh uh you see actually visually see
things happening
and i think one of the big problems that
uh
i see a lot and i ran into myself is
when you're running this at night
and you never see your irrigation
operate
um that's that's that's that's not good
and i think to actually see your system
operate
see what it's doing to the surfaces and
uh
and and i think that to operate it
during the daytime just visually check
it i think is a lot of what
i would say but um yeah uh that's a big
that's a big it's it the automatic
systems really seduce you
into applying more water than you need
and i guess that's when i would point
back to a lot of those practices that we
talked about
in the slides was using those to guide
you
uh and and the water meter to guide you
if you have
you know you have a number here that you
know you start to wilt to lose grass at
and you start approaching that number
then you go ahead and you start watering
and that gives some people the
confidence to
maybe let things go a little longer than
they might normally would so
instead of going by the seat of your
pants uh try to use some of the data
that we showed in the slide presentation
to help you make those decisions
yeah and you know the other thing i
think rick and you did a great job of
your presentation going through this
you know small system to big system and
as you move to those bigger systems
whether it's the impact sprinkler single
row to triple row
you get more heads there's more
responsibility there's more
need for you know constant irrigation
checking and updating and repairs
so there's this idea that that as you
scale up there's there's
more need to be more precise in in your
management not only of repair but of
of of checking moisture areas um so
when when you got to locust hill can you
just talk about how you used
um you know you talked about that
infrared data you really use data and
documentation to argue for a system like
that
because it would help the club you know
when we when we got through our surveys
we
we saw those documentation portions
whether it's the drought emergency plan
or a map of runoff areas people didn't
do those
very well and so could you speak to how
you use that documentation
version to advocate for resources at
your club or
you know justify water use i need x
amount of water to keep the golf course
alive
can you talk about the importance of
documenting that stuff and keeping some
data
uh not just to have it on a piece of
paper but to actually use it whether
it's to advocate for resources or to
justify
water use on the golf course yeah i
think
uh you know i think one thing that
people don't uh
connect uh with water use is the amount
of electricity it takes to operate your
pumps
if you're not if you're not uh paying
for water you're paying for electricity
to run your pumps and my electricity at
local still could run 18 to 20 000
a year and that that speaks uh volumes
with members
um so if you can reduce that for them
but in the most
in mostly though they're they're
concerned about plane conditions
and uh one of the one of the things i
can say was
uh i was in an actually in a meeting uh
promoting the new irrigation system and
i pulled up that
uh infrared slide and i had a member
say to me said rick we were told by the
last superintendent
that the irrigation system was going to
be like rainfall
and i pulled up the infrared photo and i
said that's not rainfall
and so it kind of sold it right there
but another big selling point for me at
locust hill was to eliminate the hand
watering
because with that triple roll system i
had so much better coverage and
uniformity
that we were able to reduce the hand
watering down to a very very small
amount
and that was a big thing with the
members was to maybe get those hoses and
get those people out of the fairways
um and and that kind of thing so
but i did see that you know you you try
to you put in these
triple row systems with the idea you're
going to use less water because you've
got better uniformity
but again it's a seductive thing it
seduces you into using it more than you
should and you can really over auto much
quickly
much more quickly than you could um but
uh but essentially i would say that as
far as local store went that infrared
photo really
really showed a lot now you can use it
the water meter now
like i said the catch can test there's a
lot of other things that you can
use to establish that data and and
and provide that with them so um there
were a lot a lot of
a lot of things that i used to help to
try to sell that going forward and
uh the bigger thing was uh again uh when
you when you're dealing with a
membership is playability
and if you can improve playability and
uh
you know like i say i mean when i
arrived there we had the wet spots in
the middle of the fairway and we had dry
spots on the edge of the fairway
anything you can do to make that
experience better for the golf course
golfers uh
i think is a plus okay
we are at the witching hour fellas uh
rick
carl thank you very much and big thanks
to our partners at rit
the pollution prevention institute for
providing the resources for this for us
to work together
which is of course provided by the dec
through the state of new york so we're
really happy
to be partnering with the state on this
project to be able to bring the
university
uh the state the pollution prevention
institute
uh and of course practitioners like rick
slattery uh
into the mix to help improve
implementation of these important
practices so
without any further ado i'll thank you
both very much uh for joining me uh rick
again
so great to hear from you carl it's such
been a pleasure working on this project
with you guys and we'll look forward to
the other three installments
that we will have announcements for in
the coming weeks thank you all very much
and i hope you have a wonderful day this
has been a production of
cornell university on the web at
cornell.edu